unlock your potential with world famous  magicians  andy duckerman is back baby  hey where you going i'm right here it's  been too long i thought you'd given up  magic i'm doing private shows around the  world for super important people  whatever my bunk is gonna beat you just  like i did every summer when we were  kids this is ridiculous  you know what's ridiculous how bad  you're gonna live  show me what you got this is actually my  first year here  you're all newbies this is the moment  that i disappear in a puff of smoke  they have zero skills they're hopeless  dude i was just fooling around  oh i can work with this  [Music]  what if i told you we have a chance to  win the top hat competition  who's with me if we say yes can we eat  you want to compete against me you're  insane  be prepared for anything  oh i know how you do it double stick  tape  sick burn you teach him that spoiler  alert  you